Rich Eisen joining us here and he'll be
ready to take over the Rich Eisen show
coming up the top of the hour and you're
about 30 feet away literally there is a
door that separates us it's through that
door that's my set is on the other side
and you are right it is so awesome here
and you know all those years where I was
just a guest on your show at all the
Super Bowls I would tell you all the
time yeah that the sets that DirecTV
built for you envy of the entire
industry truly you know and and now the
fact that I'm right next door it's it's
great I'm fired up h77 3dp show email
address DPA Dan Patrick comic love and
the poll question brought you by man
versus food on Travel Channel what is it
hey hold on can I guess what it is yes
it would Brady be better without
Belichick does does Belichick need Brady
to be great yes or no which one would be
better off without the other Brady or
Belichick
I'm hold on a minute I'll hold on this
is it this one sounds like mclovin more
than any of them
okay now you saw my tweet you know where
I'm going with this one is full success
proof that Wentz is a system idea
because everyone knows it's gloving is
the ultimate system at Falls just plug
and play man plug and play they're here
across the street in six days come on
but also you don't need to have a
franchise quarterback to get to the
Super Bowl well I mean oh and the
franchise quarterback got them the one
seed that I think they truly wanted to
get to this box I'm sorry I've got my
armor on this week because I just you
know when you've got six days to fill
then you know you can fall into that pit
but I don't I didn't mean to paint with
such a broad stroke by that you're gonna
start well give him mine and forgiving
the pole question is sort of in that
genre what's it gonna be the biggest
storyline Tom Brady's legacy Brady
Belichick future Eagles fan
being rowdy or Rob Gronkowski's health
whatever Gronk's health is a non-issue I
think I think that he'll be out there on
Sunday the fact that he's not gonna be
there tonight potentially because he's
still in concussion protocol so you
can't you can't have 60 minutes of
questioning I I think that he's already
been out there in the practice field so
if he can't be around bright lights
why is he outside running around in a
practicing so I think that's gonna be a
non-starter although tonight if he is
not at media night because he's still in
concussion protocol that will just add
to the list of concerns for us to talk
about even though I don't think it is
one the rowdiness I don't think we're
gonna hit that one it's it's to me it's
the Brady legacy still you know and it
we will definitely get bored some or at
least us and our some of our colleagues
you will see a topic bar this week dis
Brady need a sixth Super Bowl trophy
does he need one that's gonna be like
does he really need one to be put over
the top because Joe Montana and Bradshaw
came here four times and didn't lose I
mean we're gonna see that sort of stuff
what if the Eagles win by the way
because they're playing no I'm not just
saying that they show up I think they
really have a true shot because the
because again this is the seventh Super
Bowl that I've covered with the NFL
Network that has the Patriots in it this
is my 15th with them so I can do this in
my sleep
the the quintessential Belichick takes
away the one thing that you do best
so what is that for the Eagles
essentially that's Wentz and he's
already been taken away so who do you
take away which one of the receivers
which one of the many running backs
there isn't one so I don't know what New
England can do defensively that they
normally do against the opponent in the
Super Bowl so what is the ultimate
weapon on Philadelphia that you take
that away right I mean that's lenses
that guy essentially you would get if
you would have pointed out that's the
guy and then the football gods took him
away with a knee injury and four
honestly what he did against the Vikings
and that NFC Championship game was
stunning I did not see that coming at
all
and the run-pass option RP oh by the way
it's gonna be the the RPO is this set
the edge right of Super Bowl 50 - okay
that so we're gonna hear RPO is not big
on it what if you played an RPO drinking
game this week I mean could you make it
past Monday could you make it past today
I don't know so but that's the that's
the rules doesn't run for the run-pass
option whence would give you the RPO
Foles does not and Brady doesn't give
you an RP oh right
but I don't think the the concern is
that Foles is going to run it's he's
going to pass and if he does not he does
not hand it off that's the run-pass
option okay so it's not as if he is the
concern of wait he still has it but he's
gonna run no he wait he still has it
he's going to throw it and they disguise
it so well it's not just the running
backs it's a galore that comes across
that on occasion they'll give it to him
you saw it against Atlanta you saw it
against Minnesota so they're coached up
and I think they're dangerous team on
Sunday
if you're in Minneapolis for the big
game you can hear the show live every
morning this week at 8:00 on alt 93
three rich and I are taking over 93 3
all week long the show from 8:00 to
11:00 and then rich from 11:00 to 2:00
only on old 90 33 in Minneapolis all
right this was earlier this morning so
we were just starting the show and we
got wind of Brady's appearance on WEEI
I'm not hurting us yet
okay so Brady is usually there on
Mondays during the football season I
don't know if he does non football
season but he's there and you know he's
basically unplugged Brady gives you a
lot if you're a patriot fan they ask him
questions on WEEI the morning show and
there was a show that took place I think
over the weekend and this so Tom versus
time as a documentary coming up right
and one of the host Alex reamer
commented on what he saw of Tom versus
time on the documentary and he said the
following what you think it was fine hey
that's fine come on all right
the first scene was so staged we're
Brady's like in the kitchen
his kids being an annoying little piss
sad thing so it was five right yeah
five-year-old daughter five-year-old
daughter
oh boy and that description pretty tough
so Brady was on this morning and he was
just I have not heard this is he
responded to the criticism of his
five-year-old daughter this way you know
I don't I yeah you want to say something
I mean I don't want to get into the
documentary much but I did you know I
Stacey had told me that someone had made
a comment about my daughter yes Tom we
were just talking about it was Alex
Reimer and you're you can we Jerry and I
talked about the Friday it was a stupid
thing to say we destroyed him for saying
it you we can say whatever you like go
ahead well I think that you know I tried
to come on this show for many years with
and showed you guys a lot of respect
I've always tried to come on and you
know do a good job for you guys so you
know it's very disappointing when you
hear that certainly with my daughter any
child you know they certainly don't
deserve that so no no no question is as
I said Jerry Jerry and I popular on
Friday you understand as a professional
athlete you're gonna be criticized for
what you do or on or off the field as an
individual but for a kid to be
criticized Tommy
unbelievably stupid there's there's no
defense for it yeah so I'll obviously
evaluate whether I want to come on this
show again so I I really don't have much
to say this morning that's fine I
understand that's totally fine I will uh
maybe I'll speak with you guys some
other time absolutely fun we understand
that all right Tommy - ooh
so then was that added the the dial tone
right was that added there Polly no
actual doubt actual don't boy oh boy
I like that they they serve up this
radio host quickly like it's Alex Raymer
it's not as if we've created an entire
station of all the time where attacks
are acceptable and whatever oh gosh
whatever what else you got for me dan
what Brady be asked about this tonight
oh he'll be asked about everything
tonight and you know then we'll be asked
about it again when somebody from
another country cycles through I mean
that literally what tonight's about how
important I know it's that there's not
much to talk about with opening night
where it's me it's media night right but
I don't know how bossy an it will be
important I'm guessing but but to what
degree does anybody care about this guy
saying something about his daughter on
WEEI I I don't know unless everybody
wants to take stock about what the tenor
of sports conversation is in that town
does anybody want to do that
I don't know that's basically what that
story is it's well it's almost like
blonde angels look at Boston in it's
like I mean where where one host feels
free to say something like that I feel
like look I I don't listen to that
station when I go into town I I don't
know but all I know is this is that if
he is asked the question tonight he
could just basically say that's you know
I know he could easily handle it but he
can be asked about it five six different
times just about everything the ESPN
story that was out a few weeks ago yeah
there his hand stitches I mean but he
look this is his seventh big wave
tonight this it's a seventh podium
tonight knows but no team removes the
oxygen from a story quite like the New
England Patriots series the whole
Garoppolo Brady thing that came to a
head with the trade and then whatever
Seth Wickersham was reporting would have
consumed any other team in the training
can you imagine a season this was the
Steelers because the Steelers can't let
stuff go they're terrible and the thing
that's amazing is is that the Steelers I
think put Mike Tomlin out in front of a
podium once a week I think it's Tuesday
and that's it
Belichick speaks almost every day for
somebody that supposedly doesn't like
talking to the media or doesn't want
to talk to the media or a team that
doesn't want to have media led in yeah
he talks a heck of a lot to the media it
seems like it's almost 3-4 times a week
he doesn't say much when he gets in
front no well I mean you got to ask the
proper question to get him started I
think which is always just have him try
and wax rhapsodic about mark Bavaro or
something like that to get him going
and then and then you can ask him
something that maybe want an answer to a
coach could you talk about Navy football
yeah and then off you go give you ten
minutes right exactly so but just don't
ask him about injuries or his game plan
or Brady right or anything that's going
on G yeah but he might get that tonight
but again he's he's been through these
media nights before this is his seventh
as a head coach it really is
unbelievable when does your pregame show
start cuz we're a noon local okay for
the pregame your noon local I think it
starts or whatever is not a 7:00 a.m.
7:00 a.m.
Super Bowl central Sunday local time
it'll be no 8 a.m. pardon me so it'll be
8:00 in the morning and then we're eight
and a half hours long yeah you're
laughing I was starting to feel like god
I got to do a five hour pregame eight
and a half yeah now I feel better
well last year okay for the first time
normally here's what happens whoever
spends the money to Ho to broadcast the
Super Bowl has rights to the field by
certain times we get kicked off yeah and
then about an hour or two before that
happens we lose the right to show NFL
footage the NFL Network cannot show
footage of the NFL because then
broadcast partner that's broadcast and
rightfully so has that right yes yes
well I mean yes we can go back and forth
you know that's a pissant comment oh now
I've got to think about whether I want
to come back on the show and
my men can do that but in all honesty so
last year though that they stuck us out
for the last 90 minutes outside in
Houston so they're gonna do that again
this year but in a hermetically sealed
like booth so last year when I went
outside for the extra hour and a half
that I'm not normally used to doing I
got totally slap-happy and turned to the
fans who are still sitting behind the
set even though kickoff is an hour away
at the Super Bowl I screamed at them go
inside they wanted to be on TV
I guess people love being on TV they do
as well you're about to be my first
guest they're at the top of the owner
and I have a friend of yours that you'll
be handing off at the end of the week
that's sitting next to the the chair
the Vince Lombardi Trophy is on the
other side of the door Vinnie is in
there
yeah what do you want me to do me to
bring it over you know why don't you
why'd you bring it over oh my god I got
Michael Irvin coming up here the
playmaker Mike's held that thing before
a couple of times so I got so Rich's
going next door to the Rich Eisen show
you need gloves for that trophy I can't
remember what now rich got upset with me
last year in Houston when he had the
Vince Lombardi Trophy and on I put my
grubby fingers on it and and then he
said you're not allowed to do that so
then like a little kid you know when the
stove is hot and they say don't touch it
then I touched it cuz the trophy is so
shiny when you get one big print down it
just really throws the whole thing oh
yeah and so but you can't be seen
wearing like white gloves
no but they he would appreciate if I
wore the white glove I gave the white
Club treatment though I mean jerky yeah
why are you eating jerky because Traeger
brother furniture okay so here come Oh
rich has the white gloves on oh look at
that oh hardware there now if I if I
wear the white gloves can I hold the
trophy when I'm on your show okay
because last year you got mad at me
because I just grabbed it well it's
there are rules Dan there are rules that
even those whose job it is to hand the
things out by the end of the week I'm
not gonna have white gloves on Sunday
and I think they just you know gloves
are off Sunday
that's Super Sunday loves our own eye so
I'll see you in about 45 minutes VLT
will be there too yes all right
the Vince Lombardi Trophy event that's
VLTs there's a Rich Eisen Rich Eisen has
left the room for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]